Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. Back in the mists of time when we were mere podcasting novices, when we recorded our very first episode, we hit on the subject of greatness. And today's podcast is about a man we talked about a lot in that first episode without ever really getting into his story. And it is probably the greatest story
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的 restis》。回溯到很久以前，当我们还只是播客新手时，在录制第一期节目时，我们就偶然谈到了“伟大”这个主题。而今天的播客讲的是一个我们在第一期节目中经常谈到、却从未真正深入了解其生平的人。这可能是有史以来最伟大的故事，
in all history it is of course alexander the great tom holland there's probably no greater character no better story no more glamour and excitement and romance than in the life of alexander is there it's a great story i thought thought it was really interesting. And I was surprised that when I put the note up on Twitter saying we were going to do Alexander the Great, the response was absolutely overwhelming. I don't think we've ever had as many replies or questions, have we? I don't think we even had, I don't think we had more questions even for Hitler than we did for Alexander. And Sam, a heroic kind of backroom boy who he was basically ploughing through hundreds of questions in order to try and whittle them down a little bit.
在整个人类历史上，他当然就是亚历山大大帝。汤姆·霍兰，在亚历山大的一生中，大概没有比这更伟大的性格、更好的故事、更多的魅力、兴奋和浪漫了吧？确实是个伟大的故事，我觉得非常有意思。当我在推特上发消息说我们要讲亚历山大大帝时，反响之热烈让我大吃一惊。我想我们从来没有收到过这么多的回复和提问，对吧？我想我们甚至没有……连希特勒都没有收到比亚历山大更多的提问。山姆，一个幕后英雄，他基本上过目了数百个问题，以便试图把它们精简一些。
Well, I was reassured. And I'll tell you why. It was because I went to this fantastic literary festival held at Patrick Lee Furmer's house on the shore of the Peloponnese. And there was a kind of a parlor game type thing in the evening where we all had to make an argument for who was the greatest Greek. And obviously I chose Alexander the Great because he's great. And I thought, of course, I'm going to walk this.
嗯，我感到很放心。我来告诉你原因。那是因为我去了一个极棒的文学节，它在帕特里克·李·弗默（Patrick Leigh Fermor）位于伯罗奔尼撒海岸的宅邸举办。那天晚上有一个类似客厅游戏的环节，我们所有人都必须为“谁是最伟大的希腊人”提出一个论点。显然我选择了亚历山大，因为他是伟大的。我想，这还用说，我肯定能轻松胜出。
And Bethany Hughes chose Helen of Troy. And we came joint bottom. Oh, no. Oh, my God. Who won? Aristophanes because he would have opposed Brexit. That's a terrible. That's such an indictment of that whole occasion. So that may reflect the fact that i made a terrible case for him and i
然后贝瑟尼·休斯（Bethany Hughes）选择了特洛伊的海伦。结果我们俩并列倒数第一。哦，不。天哪。谁赢了？阿里斯托芬，因为他会反对英国脱欧。这太糟糕了。这简直是对整个活动莫大的讽刺。所以这可能反映出我为他做了一个糟糕的辩护，而我
think i'd rather but yeah but i think it also reflects um a kind of tension in uh attitude towards alexander now that we actually discussed in our very first right there he is obviously i mean he's a great figure he's the essence greatness. He's the first person to be called great. That's the whole point of him. But there's a slight ambivalence now towards him that perhaps wasn't there earlier. So there was this whole kind of, the heyday of the British Empire,
我想我宁愿……不过，是的，我觉得这也反映了一种……对亚历山大态度的某种紧张感，这种态度我们在第一期节目里其实就讨论过。看，他显然是个伟大的人物，他就是伟大的本质。他是第一个被称为“伟大”的人。这正是他的关键所在。但现在人们对他的态度产生了一种微妙的矛盾，这在早期可能是不存在的。所以当时有这样一种整体的氛围，在大英帝国的全盛时期，
there was this idea that he was selflessly conquering the world for the good of the subject people, which obviously went down rather well. and now that kind of attitude is um but it's a certain degree of a scarce it's a tremendous adventure story isn't it i think you've got a question from stephen clark is that right so i'm just queuing you up yeah i don't know what you're talking about oh yes so i do yes so a question from stephen clark a friend of the show. Yeah, great man. Great man in his own right. A friend of Dominic.
有一种观点认为，他是在无私地为了被征服人民的利益而征服世界，这种观点显然相当受欢迎。而现在这种态度……不过，这是一个非常了不起的冒险故事，对吧？我想你有一个来自斯蒂芬·克拉克的提问，对吗？所以我只是在给你 cue 流程。哦，我不知道你在说些什么。哦，是的，我是说有的。所以，这是一个来自斯蒂芬·克拉克的问题，他是节目的老朋友。是的，伟人。凭他自己也是个伟人。多米尼克的友人。
I mean, this is a shameful question. It's the top question that Sam chose of all the questions. It is. You put it at the top of the sheet. Oh, God. I'm losing the will to live. Why did Dominic choose Alexander the Great as one of his Adventures in Time series? So, Dominic, Adventures in Time.
我的意思是，这是一个令人汗颜的问题。这是山姆从所有问题中选出的头号问题。确实是。你把它放在表格的最顶端了。天哪。我都要失去活下去的意志了。为什么多米尼克会选择亚历山大大帝作为他的“时间历险”系列的主角之一呢？那么，多米尼克，“时间历险”。
This is your series of children's books. You did an earlier one on Henry VIII on the Second World War. You've got one on the First World War, which is why we're going to be doing Remembrance Sunday as our next episode. It's a complete coincidence. It's a massive coincidence. And you've chose Alexander the Great. What story did you have to miss out or severely edit
这是你的儿童读物系列。你之前写过一本关于亨利八世和第二次世界大战的书。你还写了一本关于第一次世界大战的书，这也是为什么我们要把“阵亡将士纪念星期日”作为下一期节目的原因。这完全是个巧合。这是一个巨大的巧合。而你选择了亚历山大大帝。你不得不略去或大幅删减了哪个故事，
to ensure your book about Alexander is appropriate for children? Funnily enough, I don't think I really did have to miss any stories out. Did you miss out Baguas? Baguas actually has been massively inflated. So Baguas is the Persian eunuch that he supposedly has an affair with. One of the top eunuchs. He was one of our top eunuchs. Baguas'
以确保你关于亚历山大的书适合儿童阅读？说实话，我觉得我真的没有漏掉什么故事。你漏掉了巴戈阿斯（Bagoas）吗？巴戈阿斯其实被大大夸大了。所以巴戈阿斯是那个据说与他有染的波斯太监。最顶级的太监之一。他是我们的顶级太监之一。巴戈阿斯
appearance in the sources are slight at best. So did you leave him out? No, there's one fleeting mention of him when I'm talking about Alexander adopting Persian customs. He's got a great friend called Bagwas. That's nice. A great pal. But no, I think – why did I choose it?
在史料中的出场充其量也只是惊鸿一瞥。所以你把他漏掉了吗？不，当我谈到亚历山大采用波斯风俗时，对他有过一次转瞬即逝的提及。他有一个很好的朋友叫巴戈阿斯。那挺好的。一个好哥们。但没有，我想——我为什么选择它？
Well, why are we doing it on this podcast and why are we going to give it two episodes? I mean, the answer is because it is probably the single most exciting story in all history. I think the only one that would really compare would be the arrival of- It's the Persian invasion of Greece. I would not say that. Not even Watergate. Or indeed the Jeremy Thorpe scandal. I would say it's probably the arrival of the conquistadors in the new world.
好吧，为什么我们在本期播客中讲述他，为什么我们要用两期节目来介绍他？我的意思是，答案是因为这可能是整个历史上最惊心动魄的故事。我想唯一能真正与之媲美的，就是……那是波斯人入侵希腊。我可不会这么说。甚至不是水门事件。或者甚至是杰里米·索普丑闻。我会说这大概相当于征服者到达新世界。
For the sheer kind of- Almost science fiction level drama i mean the idea that alexander you know he fights his first major battle when he's 18 when he's 20 he's king he leads his men for a decade on this unbelievably strange and exacting journey where they go to places that they've they could barely imagine they're climbing mountains. They see the pyramids. They travel for, I think, historians have worked out, they keep going for about 22,000 miles. And they just keep going. And at the end, he thinks he's going to get to the end of the earth.
那种纯粹的……几乎达到科幻级别的戏剧性。我的意思是，亚历山大在18岁时打了他第一场重要战役，20岁时他就成了国王，他带领部下在长达十年的时间里进行了一次令人难以置信的陌生而严苛的征程，他们去了那些他们几乎无法想象的地方，他们爬山。他们看到了金字塔。根据历史学家的计算，他们总共行进了大约22,000英里。而且他们一直在前进。最后，他以为自己会走到世界的尽头。
I mean, it's an incredible story. And in the course of it, he conquers, he defeats the world's most biggest and richest empire. He becomes king of kings. He enters unchallenged the greatest city on earth he thinks he's a god i mean what's not to like it's just a tremendous tremendous quest narrative and i think it's one of those stories that um you read about it as a child and it it gets you into history absolutely for life and then i think you slightly put it
我的意思是，这是一个不可思议的故事。在这个过程中，他征服了、击败了世界上最大、最富有的帝国。他成为了万王之王。他毫无异议地进入了地球上最伟大的城市，他认为自己是神。我的意思是，有什么理由不爱它呢？这简直是一个极其宏大的寻宝叙事，而且我认为这是那种……你在童年时读到它，它就会让你一辈子都对历史着迷的故事，然后我想你稍微把书
away don't you because you sort of are a bit it's the kind of story i think that teenagers and people in their 20s put away because they're a bit embarrassed by it they don't want to do a seminar on it and then they come back to it later on that damn it's a good story so i think lots of you know we've talked about this before and lots of people myself included kind of get into history and perhaps particularly ancient history through the mythology greek mythology you read the trojan war and all that kind of stuff. And then you want a sequel. And in a way, Alexander is the sequel. And he's a sequel, I think for two reasons,
合上了，对吧？因为你有点……这大概是那种让十几岁和二十多岁的年轻人将其束之高阁的故事，因为他们对它有点难为情，他们不想就此进行研讨会，然后他们以后又会回过头来看它。该死，这真是一个好故事。所以我想很多人——我们以前也讨论过这个——很多人，包括我自己，都是通过神话、希腊神话进入历史领域，或许尤其是古代历史。你阅读特洛伊战争和所有诸如此类的东西。然后你想要续集。从某种意义上说，亚历山大就是续集。我认为他是续集，原因有二：
partly because he consciously models himself on Achilles. So he, he claims to be descended from Achilles and from Heracles, two great heroes. So ultimately he's, he's the descendant of Zeus. So he's wired into that world of mythology. He models himself on Achilles. He takes Iliad with him on his of Zeus. So he's wired into that world of mythology. He models himself on Achilles.
部分原因是他有意识地将自己塑造为阿喀琉斯的化身。所以他宣称自己是阿喀琉斯和赫拉克勒斯的后代，这是两位伟大的英雄。因此归根结底，他是宙斯的后代。所以他与那个神话世界紧密相连。他将自己塑造为阿喀琉斯。他把《伊利亚特》带在身边……宙斯的后代。所以他与那个神话世界紧密相连。他将自己塑造为阿喀琉斯。
He takes Iliad with him on his great adventure. He does. And so on. But I think also it's because actually the story of Alexander the Great is, it is a kind of myth because actually the sources for it are a lot more patchy precarious and late than one might want to think uh and we we on our episode of muhammad and really the story of arab conquest is the only comparison to this um if you think you know massadin is on the margins of great empires and it conquers these great empires rather in the way that the Arabs do
他把《伊利亚特》带在他的伟大冒险中。他确实带了。诸如此类。但我也认为这是因为亚历山大大帝的故事本身就是一种神话，因为实际上关于他的史料比人们想象的要零碎、不可靠得多，而且出现得更晚。我们在穆罕默德那一集里说过，阿拉伯征服的故事是唯一可以与此相提并论的……如果你认为马其顿地处伟大帝国的边缘，却征服了这些伟大帝国，这与7世纪和8世纪阿拉伯人的做法颇为相似。
in the seventh and eighth centuries. And just as the sources for the Arab conquests are late, kind of centuries later, and therefore the kind of stories that you get with lots of arrows and maps and things, and people confidently saying that the Arabs did this and they did that, you know, you've got to slightly kind of raise an eyebrow at that. Same is slightly true for Alexander, because I think the earliest account, narrative account of his life is 300 years after it. Most of the accounts that we draw on are actually written in the heyday of the Roman Empire. So in a sense are as much about the Romans as they are about Alexander himself.
正如阿拉伯征服的史料出现得很晚，比事件发生晚了几个世纪，因此你得到的那些绘有许多箭头和地图的宏大故事，以及人们信誓旦旦地说阿拉伯人这样做了、那样做了，你知道的，你对此不得不略微挑起眉毛。关于亚历山大，情况也略微如此，因为我认为关于他生平的最早记叙是在事发300年之后。我们所依据的大多数记叙实际上都是在罗马帝国的全盛时期撰写的。所以从某种意义上说，这些记叙既是关于罗马人的，也是关于亚历山大本人的。
They are. So, and on top of that, there's a further complication, which is that we have all, and this is something again that we talked about in the Thermopylae episode, we have almost nothing written sources from the Persian side. And so a bit as in a kind of romance, a nightly romance, you get the knight going out and having the adventures and you don't hear about, you know, what the dragon thought of it. So likewise with this, he leads his armies, he attacks all these people it's it's like they are just kind of exotic names they're just the stormtroopers in star wars they're kind of kind of his mail yeah i think i think i think that the great you know the the kind of the the great revolution the understanding of alexander and it was it's been pointed out by various academics that the study of alexander
确实如此。而且除此之外，还有一个更复杂的因素，那就是我们几乎所有人——这也是我们在温泉关那一集里讨论过的问题——几乎没有任何来自波斯方面的书面史料。所以，有点像在传奇故事、骑士传奇中，你看到骑士出去历险，却听不到……你知道的，龙对这一切有什么看法。与此类似，他率领军队，攻击所有人，这就像他们只是一些异国情调的名字，他们只是《星球大战》里的暴风兵，他们有点像他的……好吧，我想……我认为伟大的……那种关于亚历山大的理解的巨大革命——正如几位学者所指出的那样，对亚历山大的研究
has you know in terms of sophistication has been it's been a bit of a backwater for quite a long time. And I think that that has really begun to change. And it's chiefly begun to change because there are great scholars who have looked at the Persians and have tried to place Alexander in the context of the world that he conquers. And perhaps the greatest of them is a French scholar called Pierre Brion. He famously described Alexander as the last of the Achaemenids, and the Achaemenid is the Persian dynasty that Alexander overthrows. And I think that that actually does start to make sense of him as someone who is not a hero for myth, and is not a kind of monster, which are the two poles that tend to kind of govern how he's understood, but someone who is a brilliantly brilliantly inventive and creative
在复杂性方面，在相当长的一段时间里一直是停滞不前的。我认为这种情况确实已经开始改变。这主要是因为有一些伟大的学者研究了波斯人，并试图将亚历山大置于他所征服的世界的背景中。其中最伟大的或许是一位名叫皮埃尔·布里安（Pierre Briant）的法国学者。他有一句名言，将亚历山大描述为“最后一个阿契美尼德人”，而阿契美尼德王朝就是被亚历山大推翻的波斯王朝。我认为这确实开始使他变得可以理解了——他不是神话中的英雄，也不是某种怪物，而这往往是主导人们对他的理解的两个极端——而是一个极其具有创新精神和创造力的政治家，同时也是有史以来最伟大的将领之一。
politician as well as kind of one of one of the greatest generals who's ever lived and i think the way the persianness of alexander is something we'll come to because we are going to tell the story and do it in proper detail but the persian has become so important doesn't it the extent which he ceases to be macedonian or greek and becomes a king of kings like he never takes on that title no he doesn't he never takes on that but as we will discover he certainly takes on the appearance yes he takes on a lot of the rituals he has the costume he has the wife he has the eunuchs because he recognizes that that's the only way well let's come on we're leaving ahead yes we are let's. Well, let's, come on, we're leaping ahead. Yes, we are.
而且我认为亚历山大的波斯化是我们以后会谈到的内容，因为我们要讲述这个故事并进行真正的详细探讨。亚历山大的波斯化变得如此重要，对吧？他不再是马其顿人或希腊人，而是变成了万王之王，尽管他从未采用过那个称号……不，他没有，他从来没有采用过那个称号，但正如我们将要发现的，他无疑采纳了那种外表。是的，他采纳了许多礼仪，他穿上了那套服饰，他娶了那样的妻子，他有了太监，因为他认识到那是唯一的途径……好了，我们别说了，我们跳得太远了。是的，我们确实跳得太远了。好吧，我们别说了，我们跳得太远了。是的，我们确实跳得太远了。
Let's tell the story. This is arguably the most exciting story in all history, so we should really do it justice. So let's start with where he comes from. So he comes from the Kingdom of Macedon or Macedonia. And Amy Mantrovati has a question. She says, who gets to claim him, Greece or Macedonia or North Macedonia, as it's now called?
让我们来讲述这个故事。这可以说是整个历史上最激动人心的故事，所以我们真的应该还原它的本来面目。让我们从他的出身开始讲起。他来自马其顿王国（Kingdom of Macedon or Macedonia）。埃米·曼特罗瓦蒂（Amy Mantrovati）有一个问题。她问，究竟是谁有权认领他，是希腊、马其顿，还是现在所谓的北马其顿？
Well, Tom, you and I have recorded a documentary about this before haven't we um we have well I think I think so there's a huge argument isn't there uh in Greece and in the former Yugoslav Republic of Macedonia yeah about who Alexander belongs to and it's an insane argument because he doesn't belong to either of them um because I think they both have every right to claim them you claim whoever you like they do but so but but in the context of the fourth century when alexander is born is macedonia greek this is this is a question that is kind of contested and debated and basically i think macedonia is greek because the macedonian kings are able to compete at the olympic games yeah and they speak a version essentially they speak a kind of dialectic greek
好吧，汤姆，你和我以前曾为此录制过一部纪录片，对吧？嗯，是的。好吧，我想……我想在希腊以及前南斯拉夫马其顿共和国，关于亚历山大究竟属于谁，存在着巨大的争论，对吧？这是一个荒谬的争论，因为他不属于他们两边中的任何一方，因为我认为他们双方都有完全的权利去认领他，你想认领谁就认领谁。他们确实可以。但……但在公元前4世纪亚历山大诞生的背景下，马其顿是希腊的吗？这是一个饱受争议和辩论的问题。基本上我认为马其顿是希腊的，因为马其顿国王有资格参加奥林匹克运动会，
now other greeks do mock them so demosthenes in athens who's a great rival of the macedonians and hates the macedonians he says they're not even proper greeks they don't they they live like dogs you can't even buy a proper slave from macedonia he says um but in oliver stone's film yeah the macedonians speak with irish accents don't they i've actually never seen i can't i've never seen the story i've loved the story of alexander so much i can't bring myself towards all of us but i think perhaps the comparison is with scotland and england maybe yes i think that's the lowlands and there's highlands exactly yeah there's a sense that
而且他们说一种本质上属于某种方言的希腊语。当然，其他希腊人会嘲笑他们。因此，雅典的德摩斯梯尼——他是马其顿人的死对头，非常痛恨马其顿人——他说他们甚至都不是真正的希腊人，他们像狗一样生活，你在马其顿甚至买不到一个像样的奴隶。不过，在奥利弗·斯通的电影里，马其顿人的口音是爱尔兰口音，对吧？我其实从来没看过……我太热爱亚历山大这个故事了，以至于我无法让自己去看奥利弗……但我想也许可以拿苏格兰和英格兰作类比，
they're warlike clannish highlanders aren't they and they've been divided and they've been a bit of a backwater and the key figure a massive figure is alexander's father philip ii who one-eyed lost a nine a siege and he unites all the clans behind his program of of basically fighting other people and conquering them and he crucially conquers some gold mines mount pangeum it gives him tons of money so he's able to basically buy off all these rival clan leaders in Macedonia. And he invents a very long spear. The Sarissa. The Sarissa.
是的，我认为低地和高地正是如此，确实如此。有一种感觉，他们是好战、抱团的高地人，对吧？他们曾经分裂，曾一度有些落后。而关键人物、一个极其重要的人物就是亚历山大的父亲腓力二世。他曾在一场围城战中失去了一只眼睛。他以征服其他人并将其吞并的纲领，将所有部族团结在自己麾下。至关重要的是，他征服了一些金矿——潘盖翁山（Mount Pangaeum），这为他带来了海量的资金，因此他基本上能够买通马其顿所有敌对的部族领袖。并且他发明了一种非常长的长矛——萨里萨长矛（Sarissa）。萨里萨长矛。
Yeah. So there's a funk master. What made his army the best in the world? That's Alexander's, but it would be Philip's as well. Technology or leadership. I've never really understood the thing about the Sarissa. Haven't you? Well, it's just a very long spear. Yeah, but obviously I haven't heard to other...
是的。所以有个放克大师……是什么让他的军队成为世界上最精锐的？那是亚历山大的军队，但这也是腓力的功劳。是技术还是领导力？我一直不太明白关于萨里萨长矛的事。你没明白吗？好吧，它只是一根很长的长矛。是的，但显然我没有听说过其他……
But also they have different kind of shields. They have kind of smaller shields. They're more mobile, more flexible. And they have leather helmets rather than metal ones. I think the Greeks they're fighting are a bit more lumbering and sort of old-fashioned, and the Macedonians are more sort of supple and quick-moving.
而且他们有不同种类的盾牌。他们有某种较小的盾牌。他们机动性更强，灵活性更高。他们戴的是皮头盔而不是金属头盔。我认为他们正在与之作战的希腊人有点笨重和老派，而马其顿人则更具柔韧性、行动更迅捷。
Yes, but I still don't entirely understand why inventing a long spear. If only you had a family member who was really into military history and could enlighten you, then you would know. Well, I've got a top classical historian on the podcast, so go with it. Well, they're very flexible.
是的，但我还是不太明白为什么要发明一根长矛。要是你有一个对军事历史非常着迷并能启迪你的家庭成员就好了，那样你就会知道了。好吧，我的播客里有一位顶尖的古典历史学家，所以就按这个思路讲吧。好吧，他们非常灵活。
They've got a long spear. They've got a nice new shield. And they're wearing less armour. They're very fast. They're very well-trained. I think they're super well-trained. They've got a long spear. They've got a nice new shield. And they're wearing less armour. They're very fast. They're very well trained. I think they're super well trained. They've got a really good cavalry wing. They do.
他们有一根长矛。他们有一面漂亮的新盾牌。他们穿的盔甲更少。他们速度极快。他们训练有素。我认为他们受过超级严格的训练。他们有一根长矛。他们有一面漂亮的新盾牌。他们穿的盔甲更少。他们速度极快。他们训练有素。我认为他们受过超级严格的训练。他们有一支非常优秀的骑兵联队。他们确实有。
So basically the Macedonian army has three... The Alexander's are great, kind of very dashing. They have the phalanx. They have these guys called the shield bearers, who are the kind of elite kind of infantry. And then they have the companion cavalry, as they're called, who are the kind of nobles. Yeah, very dashing.
所以基本上马其顿军队有三种……亚历山大的精锐部队，非常潇洒。他们有方阵。他们有被称为“持盾卫队”的人，这是精锐步兵。然后他们有被称为“伙伴骑兵”的部队，也就是贵族们。是的，非常潇洒。
They don't have stirrups, do they? No. And they always look for gaps in the lines and then they slice in. They do. Which is very much what Alexander does. So Philip is this sort of tremendous warlord who is basically bent on subduing the other Greek states to his will and creating a kind of informal empire in Greece, I suppose, isn't he?
他们没有马镫，对吧？没有。他们总是寻找战线上的缺口然后切入。他们确实这么做。这正是亚历山大所做的。所以腓力就是这种极其厉害的军阀，他基本上决心让其他希腊城邦臣服于他的意志，并在希腊建立某种非正式的帝国，我想是这样的吧？
But he has a justification for that, which is taking vengeance on Persia. Yes. For having burnt the Acropolis. Exactly. In 480 BC. So his sort of plan is, you know, if you're looking out from Macedonia, you say, well, I will deal with the other Greek city-states and bring them into my orbit. And then once they are on side, we can all go and attack the very very rich greek-speaking cities
但他为此找到了一个正当理由，那就是向波斯复仇。是的。因为波斯人在公元前480年烧毁了卫城。正是如此。所以他的计划大致是这样的：如果你从马其顿的角度向外看，你会说，“嗯，我会对付其他希腊城邦，把他们纳入我的势力范围。一旦他们站在我们这边，我们就可以一起去攻击那些极其极其富有、说希腊语的城市——
of what's now turkey um the very western fringe of the persian empire because they are loaded sardis halicarnassus miletus you know that tons of money i'll be incredibly rich and popular everybody will say hurrah for me because i've beaten the persians you know it's kind of win win basically well or will they or will they so there's there's two attitudes to this in greece one represented by demosthenes you've mentioned the great orator in athens um who regards this as a massive scam yeah and philip has a crook and the whole thing is kind of highfalutin nonsense which is designed to provide a justification for the macedonian takeover and then you have other greeks who are inspired by a guy called Socrates, who sees it as
也就是现在的土耳其境内、波斯帝国的极西边缘”，因为那里富得流油：萨尔迪斯、哈利卡那索斯、米利都，你知道的，有成吨的财富。我将变得极其富有和受欢迎，每个人都会因为我击败了波斯人而对我欢呼喝彩，你知道的，这基本上是一个双赢的局面。嗯……或者会这样吗？或者会这样吗？所以在希腊有两种截然不同的态度：一种以你刚才提到的雅典伟大演说家德摩斯梯尼为代表，他认为这是一个巨大的骗局，
the Greek mission to subdue barbarians. Yeah, and that's a real thing. That's not just a sort of, it's not just a scam, because ideologically, people do believe in that, don't they? They do. Well, they do. So it could be a bit of both. But essentially, you know, there are people in Greece who are backing Philip in this. And there are others who see him essentially as a kind of shyster. Yeah. And maybe he's a bit of both both he's Val Kilmer in the film isn't he I think that's absolutely ludicrous casting well I we really need to see it before we talk about it it's true this is a sensational advert for our forthcoming um live show at the Odeon Leicester Square so we've promoted two things doing cinema yes nice it's really good the fact we're talking about a film that neither of us have seen yeah that bodes very well yes it really does so anyway philip has multiple wives but one of them
腓力是个骗子，整件事都是高调的无稽之谈，其目的只是为了给马其顿的接管提供正当理由；然后你还有其他希腊人，他们受到一个叫苏格拉底的人的启发，将这视为希腊征服野蛮人的使命。是的，这是一种真实的观念。这不仅仅是一种……这不仅仅是一个骗局，因为在意识形态上，人们确实相信这一点，对吧？确实如此。嗯，他们确实相信。所以这可能两者兼而有之。但本质上，你知道，希腊确实有人在支持腓力的这一举动。而另一些人则本质上把他看作某种江湖骗子。是的。或许他两者兼有，他就像电影里的方·基默一样。我觉得这个选角简直荒谬透顶。好吧，我们在谈论它之前真的需要看一看这部电影。确实如此。这为我们即将于莱斯特广场ODEON影院举办的现场演出做了一场耸人听闻的广告。所以我们宣传了两件事：去电影院看电影，是的，太好了。我们竟然在讨论一部我们谁都没看过的电影，这兆头可真好。是的，确实如此。无论如何，腓力有很多妻子，但其中一位
is this uh raven haired um woman called olympias from epirus uh who alossians yes she um is terrifying she yes there's a lot of stuff going on with sorcery and with snakes with her that other Greeks find a bit disconcerting. So it's claimed she spends all her time with these sort of necromancers fiddling with snakes and she takes the snakes to bed, which other Greeks say is
是这位黑发女子，名叫奥林匹亚丝，来自伊庇鲁斯，摩罗西亚人……是的，她……她太吓人了。是的，她身上发生了很多关于巫术和蛇的事情，这让其他希腊人感到有点不安。据称她把所有时间都花在跟这些类似死灵法师的人一起摆弄蛇上，她还带着蛇上床睡觉，其他希腊人认为这是
poor form. Including Philip. But she gives birth... Hello, darling. Oh! I wasn't expecting that. including philip but she gives birth yes hello darling that wasn't expecting that so she gives birth anyway uh in what is it uh 353 56 exactly to alexander uh which means alexandros defender of the people i think it means um and yeah he he famously now it's his education is really important because it's part of his sort of mystique and his romance isn't it he's brought up with a load of lads yeah basically there's a sort of boarding school yes and they're all great chums
极其失礼的行为。包括腓力在内。但她生下了……嗨，亲爱的。哦！我没料到会这样。包括腓力在内，但她生下了……是的，嗨，亲爱的，我没料到会这样。无论如何，她生下了……在……是多少年？公元前356年左右，确切地说是亚历山大，这意味着“亚历山德罗斯”——人民的捍卫者，我想这是这个名字的意思。是的，他……众所周知，现在他的教育非常重要，因为这是他的神秘感和传奇色彩的一部分，对吧？他是和一大群小伙子一起长大的。是的，基本上就像寄宿学校一样。
yeah very good chums very good chums And these are the chums who will accompany him. It's like the Billy Bunter stories or something. And his chief chum is a chap called Hephaestion. Yeah, Patroclus to his Achilles. They really fancy themselves, don't they, as the sort of reincarnation of these heroes of old. And who does Philip get to be his tutor? He gets Aristotle.
是的，他们都是好哥们。非常好的哥们。非常好的哥们。而这些就是将陪伴他左右的哥们。这就像比利·班特（Billy Bunter）的故事或其他什么。他最好的哥们是一个叫赫费斯提翁的家伙。是的，他是亚历山大的帕特洛克罗斯。他们真的很把自己当成古代这些英雄的转世，不是吗？腓力请谁来当他的家庭教师？他请了亚里士多德。
Who else? He gets the top philosopher of the day. So that tells you how rich Philip is, I think. Well, he's destroyed Aristotle's hometown, hasn't he? He has. He has indeed. And so he's able to kind of get Aristotle along by saying that he'll basically make up for that. And they go to this sort of lovely wooded place called Mieza.
还能有谁？他请来了当时顶尖的哲学家。所以这说明了腓力有多富有，我想是的。嗯，他已经摧毁了亚里士多德的家乡，不是吗？他确实毁了。他的确毁了。所以他能够把亚里士多德请来，说他基本上会弥补这一点。他们去了那个美丽如画、树木繁茂的地方，叫米埃扎（Mieza）。
And they walk in groves and talk about philosophy and all this sort of thing. That sounds absolutely lovely to me. So we've got a question from Jordan Cox. Did Alexander consider himself an Aristotelian? I don't think he did. I don't think he would have had a concept of what that meant. But I think he was obviously very well educated. I mean, it's hard to think of anybody at the time who would have been better educated.
他们在树林里散步，谈论哲学以及所有诸如此类的事情。这听起来对我都绝对美妙。所以我们有一个来自乔丹·科克斯（Jordan Cox）的问题。亚历山大认为自己是亚里士多德学派的信徒吗？我不认为他是。我觉得他当时根本不会有这种概念。但我认为他显然受过极好的教育。我的意思是，很难想到当时有谁能受到比他更好的教育。
And we know he loved the Iliad. We know he loved mythology. It's said that he liked poetry and song and all these kinds of things. But I think the role that Aristotle plays in the myth of Alexander is that Aristotle is a great philosopher. Yeah. So, of course, Alexander the Great has to have the greatest philosopher. But it also, I mean, I don't think it's purely a sort of of that makes it sound like it's a concoction though tom which is that i mean he genuinely did teach him he i i'm not sure that that um that anything aristotle uh taught
我们知道他酷爱《伊利亚特》。我们知道他热爱神话。据说他喜欢诗歌、歌曲和所有这类事情。但我认为亚里士多德在亚历山大的神话中扮演的角色是因为亚里士多德是一位伟大的哲学家。是的，所以亚历山大当然得拥有最伟大的哲学家。但这其实……我的意思是，我不认为这纯粹是一种……汤姆，这听起来像是编造出来的，因为他确实实实在在地教过他，我……我并不确定亚里士多德教给亚历山大的任何东西，
alexander played a particular role in in enabling him to conquer the world dissing aristotle's teachings and saying i'm not dissing him i'm not diss dissing him. It's just that Alexander didn't sit around and become a philosopher. And actually, you know, Aristotle's teachings, he's very, very stern on the fact that Greeks are better than barbarians.
在使他征服世界方面发挥了什么特殊作用……贬低亚里士多德的教导并说……我没有贬低他，我没有贬低他。只是亚历山大并没有闲坐着成为一名哲学家。实际上，你知道，亚里士多德的教导非常、非常坚决地认为希腊人优于野蛮人。
But we know two things about Alexander and philosophy. We know that he went to see Diogenes, the cynic, who lived in a jar. In Corinth? In Corinth. A barrel?
但关于亚历山大和哲学，我们知道两件事。我们知道他去见了一位住在陶罐里的犬儒主义哲学家第欧根尼。在科林斯？在科林斯。一个木桶？
And was very keen to... It was a jar, Tom, not a barrel. It was a barrel. It's a a barrel. How's the barrel? It's a clay jar. It's a wine jar called a pithos. I'm so glad I've been able to instruct you about some Greek. I can't speak any word of Greek other than good morning, thank you, and so on.
并且非常渴望……那是个陶罐，汤姆，不是木桶。是个木桶。那就是个木桶。怎么会是木桶呢？是个陶罐，一种叫皮托斯（pithos）的酒罐。我很高兴我能向你普及一些希腊语知识。除了“早上好”、“谢谢”之类的话之外，我一句希腊语也不会说。
Anyway, I've got the jar in. And then when they're in India, he goes to see some philosophers, some naked philosophers, and he takes one of them with him, a man called Kalanis. The gymnosoph man called colonists the gimno sophists yeah the gimno sophists exactly so alexander he loved a bit of philosophy but darjeel is very rude to him because alexander went and said to darjeel is there anything i can do for you and darjeel says get out of the get out of the sun yeah get out of the sun well i'm sure alex Alexander found that. Because Diogenes, Diogenes in his wine jar. Yeah.
不管怎样，我总算把陶罐这个词弄明白了。后来当他们在印度时，他去见了一些哲学家，一些赤身裸体的哲学家，他还带走了一个人，一个名叫卡拉诺斯（Kalanis）的人。那群赤脚哲学家，一个叫卡拉诺斯的人。赤脚哲学家，正是如此。所以亚历山大他其实很喜欢哲学，但第欧根尼对他非常粗鲁，因为亚历山大走过去对第欧根尼说：“你有什么需要我效劳的吗？”第欧根尼说：“从阳光下走开。”是的，“从阳光下走开”。好吧，我相信亚历山大发现这一点……因为第欧根尼，第欧根尼就住在他的酒罐里。是的。
Do you know what he used to do there? He, well, he often rolled it up and down the gymnasium in Corinth, I believe. But when he was in it, he would just sit there and masturbate. Would he? Yeah. I didn't put that in the children's book. No. Because the whole thing of Diogenes was that he despised convention and custom.
你知道他以前在里面干什么吗？他……嗯，据我所知，他经常把它滚进滚出科林斯的那座体育馆。但当他在里面时，他就会坐在那儿手淫。真的吗？是的。我没把这写进儿童书里。没有。因为第欧根尼的核心主张就是他蔑视习俗和惯例。
Yes. He believed you should live like a dog, like an animal. Hence the cynic. Right, so back to the story. Alexander, all we know about him as a boy is he famously, there's a story about him taming his horse, Bucephalus. He tames this horse that costs 13 talents and is incredibly expensive. He's afraid of its own shadow.
是的。他认为你应该像狗一样、像动物一样生活。因此被称为“犬儒”。好吧，回到正题。关于亚历山大还是个男孩时的经历，我们所知道的就是有一个著名的故事，讲他驯服了他的马——布塞法洛斯（Bucephalus）。他驯服了这匹价值13塔兰特、贵得离谱的马。它害怕自己的影子。
He's afraid of its own shadow shadow so the horse then becomes part of the story i mean this is what appeals to children i think that he has this sort of horse that accompanies him almost all the quest and the medieval legend is that um uh it's it's said that whoever will tame this horse will rule the world exactly and bucephalus or Bucephalus is said to be the ancestor of the unicorn did you know that that's great isn't it so all his youth Alexander's youth Philip is fighting
它害怕自己的影子，所以这匹马后来成为了故事的一部分——我想这就是吸引孩子的地方——他有这样一匹马，几乎陪伴他完成了整个征程。而中世纪的传说则是……据说，谁能驯服这匹马，谁就能统治世界。就是这样。而且布塞法洛斯据说还是独角兽的祖先，你知道吗？这太棒了，对吧？所以在他的整个青年时期，当亚历山大的青春年少时，腓力一直在与
the other Greeks and he basically there's a battle at Chironaea I think it is yes outside Thebes yeah where they smash
其他希腊人作战。基本上在喀罗尼亚（Chaeronea）爆发了一场战役，我想是的。在底比斯城外，是的，在那里他们粉碎了
the Thebans the sacred band of the Thebans kind of once and for all don't they well in Athens so Thebes and Athens have been old enemies,
底比斯的神圣部队，彻底地、永远地粉碎了它们，不是吗？好吧，在雅典……底比斯和雅典曾经是老冤家，
but they sign up to face the Macedonian threat. Demosthenes fights at Chaeronea. And Alexander is 18, I think. Yeah, 18. He's a cavalry, slices in, and spectacular victory. Very harsh terms imposed on Thebes, because Philip had been a hostage there as a boy. That's right.
但他们联合起来面对马其顿的威胁。德摩斯梯尼在喀罗尼亚参战。而亚历山大当时18岁，我想是的，18岁。他是一名骑兵，切入敌阵，取得了辉煌的胜利。对底比斯强加了非常严厉的条款，因为腓力小时候曾在那里当过人质。没错。
He had. Yes. So Philip is always slightly harsher with Thebes. He's much, much, much more sparing towards Athens. And Alexander goes as his emissary to Athens. So I think it's the only time he goes to Athens. That's the first. Yeah.
他确实当过。是的。所以腓力对底比斯总是稍微严厉一些。他对雅典则宽容得多、多得多。而亚历山大作为他的特使去了雅典。所以我想这是他唯一一次去雅典。那是第一次。是的。
The first time he went, he takes the urns. Yes. The sacred urns with the ashes, is it, of the bones of the defeated Athenians. So then they have a big meeting in Corinth, don't they, after that? Yes, when Philip gets appointed head of all the Greeks apart from the Spartans. Yeah, Spartans. And Philip's so cross about this that all the dedications, it's, you know, in the name of Philip and all the Greeks, except for the Spartans. So petty.
他第一次去的时候，带着骨灰坛。是的。装着被打败的雅典人骨灰的神圣骨灰坛。所以在那之后，他们在科林斯开了一个大会，对吧？是的，当时腓力被任命为除斯巴达人之外所有希腊人的领袖。是的，斯巴达人。腓力对此十分生气，以至于所有的献词上都写着：奉腓力和所有希腊人之名，斯巴达人除外。真是太小肚鸡肠了。
But he's now really pumped because he thinks, great, I've basically beaten all the Greeks. They're all on side, except the Spartans. And we are going to cross the Hellespont and attack Persia. And he goes to the Delphic Oracle, Philip does. And they give him this message. Wreathed is the bull. The end is near. The one who will kill him is at hand. And Philip says to himself, well, this is tremendous. This is obviously the Persian king is going to be killed. But little does Philip know. What a twist, Tom. What a twist. What a twist. Because two years after the Battle of Currania, he gets assassinated.
但他现在真的斗志昂扬，因为他想：太好了，我基本上击败了所有的希腊人。他们都站在我们这边，除了斯巴达人。我们要穿过赫勒斯庞特海峡去进攻波斯。腓力去了德尔斐神谕所。神谕给他的信息是：公牛已被戴上花环。末日已近。取他性命之人就在眼前。腓力心里想，太棒了。这显然意味着波斯国王要被杀掉了。然而腓力做梦也没想到……多大的反转啊，汤姆。多大的反转。多大的反转。因为在喀罗尼亚战役两年后，他遇刺身亡了。
In very strange circumstances, it has to be said. And at a wedding. And the question is, who is responsible? Well, we know it's a guy called Pausanias who wields the dagger, don't we? So he's a bodyguard. But who's suborned him? Because the bodyguard gets killed. It's a bit like Macbeth.
是在非常奇怪的情况下，必须得这么说。而且是在一场婚礼上。问题是，谁该对此负责？好吧，我们知道挥舞匕首的是一个叫保萨尼亚斯（Pausanias）的家伙，对吧？所以他是保镖。但究竟是谁买通了他？因为保镖被杀掉了。这有点像《麦克白》。
Yeah. Macbeth killing all the servants. The bodyguard gets killed and executed's a bit like Macbeth. Yeah. Macbeth killing all the servants. The bodyguard gets killed and executed before he can be interrogated. So Cui Bono, who benefits from it. So perhaps a Persian agent. Yeah. Perhaps Olympias.
是的。麦克白杀死了所有的仆人。保镖在还没来得及被审讯就被杀死并处决了，这有点像《麦克白》。是的。麦克白杀死了所有的仆人。保镖被杀并处决，在还没来得及被审讯之前。所以，“Cui Bono”——谁从中受益？所以也许是波斯间谍。是的。也许是奥林匹亚丝。
Because Olympias by this point had a spectacular bust up because Philip has married Cleopatra. There's a lot of Cleopatras. A lot of Cleopatras. Who is, unlike Olympias, is Macedonian. And doesn't mess around with snakes. And has a baby who's a son. And so perhaps it's Alexander because he's already had his nose out of joint. He's gone off for kind of six months in a assault.
因为到这个时候，奥林匹亚丝和腓力已经闹翻了，因为腓力娶了克利奥帕特拉。这里有太多的克利奥帕特拉了。有太多的克利奥帕特拉。她与奥林匹亚丝不同，她是马其顿人。而且她不玩蛇。她还生了一个儿子。所以也许凶手是亚历山大，因为他当时已经很不高兴了。他赌气出走，在外历练了大约六个月。
With his mates. They've all gone with it. Yeah, they've all gone off in assault. So relations between Philip and Alexander are really, really bad. And they seem to be patched up, but maybe they're not. So we don't know. I mean, we'll never know. But the interesting thing is that there's this bizarre story
和他的哥们一起。他们全都跟着去了。是的，他们全都在赌气中离开了。所以腓力和亚历山大之间的关系非常非常糟糕。虽然他们似乎已经重修旧好，但也可能并没有。所以我们不知道。我的意思是，我们永远不会知道了。但有趣的是，在保萨尼亚斯谋杀案的背后，
behind the Pausanias murder. That Pausanias was feeling really sore. Well, I I mean literally sore because he had been raped by some other guy who Philip had then promoted
有一个奇怪的故事，说保萨尼亚斯当时感到非常痛苦。好吧，我……字面意义上的痛苦，因为他被另一个家伙强奸了，而腓力随后提拔了那个家伙，
and Pausanias was outraged at this so that might have been just the reason but anyway yes it's the wedding
保萨尼亚斯对此感到愤怒，所以这可能只是原因之一。但无论如何，是的，这是婚礼
games isn't it he's killed on his way into the stadium they chase after him kill Pausanias Alexander is now
竞技会，对吧？他在进入竞技场的途中被杀，人们追赶凶手，杀死了保萨尼亚斯。亚历山大现在成了
king he didn't have to be king and this is there's a slight element of a kind They chase after him, kill Pausanias. Alexander is now king. He didn't have to be king. There's a slight element of a kind of stitch-up with some of the commanders who are tooled up and ready to go to Persia. And the key one is Parmenio, isn't it? Yes. Who's already, I think, in Asia at this point. Or he's on the coast.
国王，他本不必成为国王的。这其中带有一点密谋的成分，一些指挥官已经全副武装、准备好前往波斯了。其中最关键的人物是帕曼纽（Parmenio），对吧？是的。他当时我想已经在亚洲了。或者他在海岸边。
Exactly. He's Philip's right-hand man. And basically, Alexander says, you'll still be commander. We'll still do the invasion. Nothing will change. I am now king. I'm going to come with you. And he's 20 years old.
正是如此。他是腓力的得力助手。基本上，亚历山大说：“你仍然会是指挥官。我们仍将进行入侵。一切都不会改变。我现在是国王。我要和你们一起去。”当时他20岁。
Yeah. And so where are we? We're about halfway through the first episode, aren't we? Going so slowly. He's 20 years old. And he goes north. He beats up various kind of tribes. He goes and fights lots of Balkan tribes first as a sort of
是的。所以我们现在到哪儿了？我们差不多进行到第一集的一半了，对吧？进展太慢了。他才20岁。他向北进军。他痛击了各种部落。他首先去和许多巴尔干部落作战，作为一种
warm-up. Just for the fun of it. They're like their friendlies before the World Cup or something. Has a kick around. Then the Thebans revolt. Yeah. And he destroys the whole city. He wipes out the whole city. Except for the house of Pindar, the famous poet. Yeah. Nice. You see that's his love of literature coming through.
热身。就为了好玩。这就像世界杯开赛前的热身赛一样。踢了一场热身赛。然后底比斯人叛乱了。是的。他摧毁了整座城。他把整座城从地图上抹去了。除了著名诗人品达（Pindar）的故居留了下来。是的。你看，这体现了他对文学的热爱。
Yes. Aristotle kicking in there. He also, he goes to the Oracle as well. You know, that's his love of literature coming through. Yes, Aristotle kicking in there. He also, he goes to the Oracle as well. You know what happens at the Oracle? The priestess says, it's not the right day. You know, you've got the wrong day. I don't do it today. And he drags her out by her hair. And she says, my son, thou art invincible.
是的。亚里士多德的影响在那里发挥了作用。他甚至……他还去了神谕所……你知道，这体现了他对文学的热爱。是的，亚里士多德的影响在那里发挥了作用。他甚至……他还去了神谕所。你知道在神谕所发生了什么吗？女祭司说：“今天不是好日子。你知道的，你挑错日子了。我今天不接待。”于是他揪着她的头发把她拖了出去，而她说：“我儿，你是不可战胜的。”
He says, great, that's what I wanted to know. Thank you very much. What a lad. Let's go. What a lad. Okay, go. What a lad. Okay, well, I think this is where we should stop for a break, shouldn't we? Yeah, this is clearly going to be about seven episodes. No, it's not.
他说：“太好了，这就是我想知道的。非常感谢。”真是个小伙子。我们走吧。真是个小伙子。好吧，走吧。真是个小伙子。好吧，走吧。嗯，我想我们该在这里停下来休息一下了，对吧？是的，这显然得拍个七集左右。不，不会的。
It's not. So we've got Alexander to the shores of the Hellespont. Yeah. He's getting ready to cross. The Persians are waiting. Greece behind him is relatively secure. What's going to happen next? Couldn't be more dramatic.
不会的。所以我们已经讲到亚历山大到达赫勒斯庞特海峡岸边了。是的。他正准备渡过海峡。波斯人在严阵以待。他身后的希腊相对安全。接下来会发生什么？
We'll see you back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to ther entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history and before we get back to alexander um i just want to mention a special offer uh for rest is history listeners that we've got from the people at UnHerd, U-N-H-E-R-D.
剧情不会更戏剧性了。休息过后，我们不见不散。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的 restis》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 restis》，在回到亚历山大之前，……嗯，我只想向《历史的 restis》的听众们介绍一个来自 UnHerd（U-N-H-E-R-D）的特别优惠。
And Dominic, UnHerd, a very fine online magazine. Very fine. Very fine. Tom, I'm loving this because this is actually about the fifth take that you've done because you kept mispronouncing yourself, Alexander, everything. So I'll do the rest of it. I'll do some of the talking anyway.
多米尼克，UnHerd 是一份非常优秀的网络杂志。非常优秀。非常优秀。汤姆，我太喜欢这个了，因为这实际上是你录的第五个版本了，因为你刚才一直在把自己名字、亚历山大以及所有东西的发音都弄错。所以我来收尾吧。不管怎样，接下来的部分我来讲一些。
UnHerd, it's an online magazine, so they say, that aims to put today's events do the rest of the, I'll do some of the talking anyway. UnHerd, it's an online magazine, so they say, that aims to put today's events in the context of broader history and philosophy. And I say, so they say, but actually we have both written for UnHerd, as some listeners will know. They aim to push back against herd mentality and publish independent thinkers. Do you try to do that, Tom? Is that what you're doing when you're writing for UnHerd? Yes, every time. And I like to think that I have pushed back against herd mentality and independence. Well done. So I could give an example of that.
UnHerd，这是一个网络杂志，据他们所说，旨在将今天的事件放入更广阔的历史和哲学背景中。我说，据他们所说，但实际上我们两个都为 UnHerd 写过稿，正如一些听众所知。他们的目标是反抗群体思维，并发表独立思考者的文章。你试过这样做吗，汤姆？你为 UnHerd 写稿时就是这么做的吗？是的，每一次。而且我愿意认为，我已经成功反抗了群体思维，并且保持了独立。干得好。所以我可以举个例子。
We're writing for Alexander today. Just like a job interview, give me an example of yours. I know. I'm passionate. I'd say I'm passionate about pushing back against herd mentality. and as an evidence for that i would offer an example of a counterfactual piece that i wrote about what would have happened had the persians conquered greece oh very apt and it was yes very apt in the car and it was uh i mentioned um livy the roman historian talking about what would have happened if alexander had invaded italy oh good for you i've also written for unheard and i love
我们今天是为了亚历山大而写的。就像面试一样，给我举一个你自己的例子。我知道。我很有激情。我会说我对反抗群体思维充满热情，作为证据，我会提供一个反事实文章的例子，关于如果波斯人征服了希腊会发生什么。哦，非常贴切。而且是的，在车里非常贴切，而且——我提到过——罗马历史学家李维谈到如果亚历山大入侵意大利会发生什么。哦，真有你的。我也为 UnHerd 写过稿，我喜欢
pushing back against herd mentality. Are you passionate about that? I'm probably not as passionate as you, but sometimes I like to go with the herd, just out of fear and cowardice. No, you don't. No, I'm joking. Of course I don't. I'm just being self-deprecating. And to be serious, Dominic, one of the things about UnHerd is that almost every, they publish kind of three or four articles every day. They do. And there is always, you know, at least one or two that makes you see things in a completely different way.
反抗群体思维。你对这个充满热情吗？我可能没有你那么热情，但有时我喜欢随波逐流，纯粹出于恐惧和怯懦。不，你才不。不，我开玩笑的。我当然没有。我只是在自嘲。说真的，多米尼克，UnHerd 的特点之一是，他们几乎每天——他们每天发表大约三四篇文章。他们确实这么做。而且总是——你知道——至少有一两篇能让你以完全不同的方式看待事物。
So there was an example last week about India, a piece about India and the challenge of looking at its history through the lens of victimhood. I remember it well. It was a jolly good article. I thought it was very interesting. So the good news for our listeners, there's tremendous news, isn't there?
所以上周有一个关于印度的例子，一篇关于印度以及通过受害者视角看待其历史的挑战的文章。我记得很清楚。那是一篇相当不错的文章。我觉得非常有趣。所以对我们的听众来说是个好消息，天大的好消息，对吧？
Great news. Absolutely. There is a special offer. It's the first three months free. It's normally one pound a week. And if you don't like it, if you don't like pushing back- Why wouldn't you like it?
好消息。绝对是。有一个特别优惠。前三个月免费。通常是一周一英镑。如果你不喜欢它，如果你不喜欢反抗——为什么会有人不喜欢？
You're part of the herd. Yes. You're part of the herd. Then you can unsubscribe. So that is unheard.com slash rest. And unheard is U-N-H-E-R-D. So unheard.com slash rest. Yeah, don't be part of the herd.
你是羊群的一部分。是的。你是羊群的一部分。那你可以取消订阅。网址是 unheard.com 杠 rest。UnHerd 的拼写是 U-N-H-E-R-D。所以是 unheard.com 杠 rest。是的，不要成为羊群的一部分。
Be part of the unheard. The unheard herd. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Alexander is at the Hellespont, Tom. He crosses the Hellespont. He throws a spear, doesn't he, to show that he's Asia. Spear one. It's his spear one prize.
成为不随波逐流的人。特立独行者。欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。亚历山大正身处赫勒斯庞特，汤姆。他跨越了赫勒斯庞特。他扔出了一支长矛，不是吗，来表明他是亚洲的主人。第一支长矛。这是他赢得亚洲的第一支长矛。
He's claiming Asia. There's a really interesting question here right at this point. What do you think that he and his officers think they're going to do well the habit of of uh crossing into uh asia and trying to to steal various cities under persian rule is a bit of a habit um greek greek generals have been doing it for you know a long time and i think that that's why uh deris the third who is the the ecumenic king uh far away in persia and his um his deputies are not unduly worried about what's going on yeah because they've seen it all before um i i think that that alexander well people call it his pothos his kind of his yearning his yearning to reach beyond the limits.
他在宣称对亚洲的主权。这里有一个非常有趣的问题。你认为他和他的军官们觉得自己接下来要做什么？嗯，跨越到亚洲并在波斯统治下窃取各个城市的习惯——这有点成了一种习惯。希腊将领们这么做已经有——你知道——很长一段时间了，我想这就是为什么远在波斯的阿契美尼德国王大流士三世和他的副手们对正在发生的事情并不感到过分担忧的原因，是的，因为他们以前见多了。我——我认为亚历山大——人们称之为他的“渴望”（pothos），他那种超越极限的渴望。
I have that with podcasting. I think it's impossible to kind of psychologize Alexander in that way because he's so removed from us. But clearly he's a man of ambition. And I think that he kind of reaches the stage, you know, basically he just keeps going and he keeps winning. Why stop? And he ends up kind of able to see the prize in front of him, but knowing that he cannot afford a single mistake. And that's what's extraordinary about the story.
我对做播客也有这种感觉。我认为以这种方式去对亚历山大进行心理分析是不可能的，因为他离我们太远了。但很明显，他是一个雄心勃勃的人。而且我想他达到了这样一个阶段，你知道，基本上他就是不断前进，不断获胜。为什么要停下来？他最终能够看到眼前的奖赏，但又知道自己承担不起哪怕一次失误的代价。这就是这个故事非凡的地方。
And that's clearly true. That he achieves what he achieves because he never once slips up badly. Yeah. He never loses a battle. He never makes a terrible strategic error. He's in tough spots, but he always gets out of it. He always gets out of them and i think that that basically the further he goes the more he wins the more tantalizing the prize becomes the more he's determined to to claim that prize and and i think the habit of
这显然是真的。他之所以能取得这样的成就，是因为他从未有过一次严重的失误。是的。他从未输过一场战斗。他从未犯下可怕的战略错误。他处境艰难，但总是能化险为夷。他总能摆脱困境，我认为基本上他走得越远，赢的越多，奖赏就越诱人，他就越决心夺取这个奖赏，而且我认为
success breeds ambition and ambition breeds success i'm sure that's true i think my theory is i don't think at this stage he thinks he's going to be king of all Persia by any means. I agree with you. I think this is like a standard thing you do. It's a jaunt. It's a gap year. And I think all his men, I mean, you can sort of tell that when they get cross with him at the very end of the quest. Because I think at this stage they think this is great.
成功孕育野心，野心孕育成功。我确信这是真的。我认为我的理论是，我不认为在这个阶段他认为自己一定会成为全波斯的国王。我同意你的观点。我认为这就像是你做的常规事情。这是一次远足。这是一个间隔年。而且我认为他所有的手下——我的意思是，当他们在探险的最后阶段对他感到生气时，你就能看出来。因为我认为在这个阶段他们觉得这太棒了。
We'll go for like a couple of years take these very rich cities i'll come back absolutely loaded and be able to buy and be able to buy like a massive farm and you know loads of land and i'll be laughing if you said to them then you'll be gone for 10 years and you're going to end up in india you're going to end up in india they'd have said thanks but no thanks you know let the guy down the road go so anyway they cross over don't they and he he does this hilarious thing when they go to the tomb of uh the grave of achilles and he takes off all his clothes pours oil over himself and runs around the tomb again and again is that is that kind of standard behavior you know more about the greek world it's fair i mean as we, it's a lad's tour. What happens on tour stays on tour. I guess so.
我们要去个一两年，占领这些非常富裕的城市，我回来时会赚得盆满钵满，能够买得起——能够买下一个巨大的农场，你知道，还有大量的土地，我会笑醒的。如果你当时对他们说，你们会离开 10 年，而且最后会去到印度，你们最终会去到印度，他们会说谢谢，但不用了，你知道，让街头的那个人去吧。所以无论如何，他们过海了，不是吗？他做了一件非常滑稽的事，当他们去阿基里斯的墓地时，他脱掉所有的衣服，把油倒在自己身上，一次又一次地绕着墓地跑步。这——这算是标准行为吗？你对希腊世界了解得更多，这很公平。我的意思是，正如我们所知，这是一场男人们的旅行。旅行中发生的事，就留在旅行中。我猜是吧。
Anyway, but it's not just running around naked, is it? He also has a Persian enemy to defeat. He does. Which he does at the Battle of the River Granicus. He does. But you said that Darius doesn't take this terribly seriously. I'm sure I absolutely agree with you because he doesn't go himself. There's a guy called Memnon of Rhodes
不管怎样，这不仅仅是裸奔，对吧？他还有一个波斯敌人要击败。他确实有。他是在格拉尼库斯河战役中击败的。他确实做到了。但你说过大流士并没有把这当成什么大不了的事。我确信我完全同意你的观点，因为他自己没有去。有一个叫罗德的门农的人
who is the Persian. So he's a Greek. So it just tells you actually. Greek mercenary, yeah. Greek mercenary. The Persians have got tons of Greek mercenaries. Memnon of Rhodes says to the Persians. Alexander has Greek contingents as well,
他是波斯人。所以他是个希腊人。所以这实际上说明了一切。希腊雇佣兵，是的。希腊雇佣兵。波斯人有大量的希腊雇佣兵。罗德的门农对波斯人说。亚历山大也有希腊特遣队，
but there's a slight sense that they're hostages as much as they're allies. Yeah. So Memnon says to the Persians, listen, just retreat scorched earth. You know, he'll take some stuff and then he'll go away. And they refuse to do that. They say, no, I will attack, you know, I'm not going to, I'm Alexander, I should attack them straight away. And which you pick as a historian basically just depends
但有一种轻微的感觉，他们既是人质也是盟友。是的。所以门农对波斯人说，听着，直接撤退，焦土抗战。你知道，他拿走一些东西然后就会离开。而他们拒绝这样做。他们说，不，我要进攻，你知道，我不会——我是亚历山大，我应该直接攻击他们。你作为一个历史学家如何看待这一点，基本上取决于
on how you see Alexander. Do you see him as calculating or do you see him as impulsive? And there's no guarantee that either of them are right. No, that's true. I mean, that's the thing. That's the problem. Anyway, let's go with the best version. They charge straight across the river
你是如何看待亚历山大的。你认为他是精于算计的，还是觉得他是冲动行事的？而且没有人能保证这两种看法哪一种是对的。不，这确实如此。我的意思是，这就是关键所在。这就是问题所在。不管怎样，我们挑最好的版本来看。他们直接冲过河去
and they basically just wipe the floor. Alexander was almost killed. But he's rescued by Black Clitus. Right, who is the brother of his old nanny, Lanike. Yes, so this is important for later. It is important. When we get to episode 27 of this Alexander quest, you will need to remember that detail.
基本上把对方杀得片甲不留。亚历山大差点被杀。但他被黑克利图斯救了。对，他就是亚历山大老奶妈拉尼克的兄弟。是的，所以这对于后来很重要。这确实很重要。当我们讲到这个亚历山大探险之旅的第 27 集时，你需要记住这个细节。
Right, so I think we need to slightly speed things up. So Alexander beats the Persians at River Granicus. He then kind of charges down. He takes all those rich cities. Now, even at that point, I think that's the first point at which you could say he could stop. He's got that coastline. But he thinks, no, I'll keep going. Why would I stop?
好吧，所以我觉得我们需要稍微加快一点进度。所以亚历山大在格拉尼库斯河击败了波斯人。然后他一路冲下去。他占领了所有那些富裕的城市。现在，即使在那个时候，我认为这也是你可以说他可以停下来的第一个时间点。他已经拥有了那条海岸线。但他想，不，我要继续前进。我为什么要停下来？
The Persians are nowhere to be seen. So I'll just kind of keep going. He goes to a place called Gordium and he cuts the Gordian knot. He has a famous knot. Yes. The only town in the world with a famous knot, I think. Well, except that he ruins it. Well, you know who tied that knot, Tom? It was Heracles, wasn't it?
波斯人连影子都见不到。所以我还是继续前进吧。他去了一个叫戈耳狄俄姆的地方，并解开了戈耳狄俄斯之结。他有一个著名的结。是的。世界上唯一一个拥有著名结的城镇，我想是的。嗯，除了他把它给破坏了。好吧，你知道是谁系了那个结吗，汤姆？那是赫拉克勒斯，对吧？
No, Midas. King Midas. Midas. Of gold fame and asses' ears. So Midas had ridden into Gordium with his father, Gordias, who became king, and they tied up the cart and this great knot. And whoever cuts the knot, or sorry, whoever unties the knot will become lord of all Asia. And Alexander stands there and everyone's staring at him. He sets himself a very high, you know,
不，迈达斯。迈达斯国王。迈达斯。以点金术和驴耳朵闻名。所以迈达斯和他的父亲戈耳狄俄斯一起骑马进入了戈耳狄俄姆，后者后来成了国王，他们把大车和这个巨大的结系在了一起。谁能解开这个结，或者抱歉，谁能解开这个结，谁就能成为全亚洲的主宰。亚历山大站在那里，所有人都盯着他看。他给自己设定了一个非常高的——你知道的——
because he's going to look like a fool if he can't untie this knot. People are standing with their phones, boys, you know because he's gonna look like a fool if he can't on instagram yeah it's not people are standing with their phones boys you know and so eventually just takes out his sword and cuts it hurrah he's cut the gordian knot hence the expression yeah and so that proves he's going to conquer asia right and so it happens so he he um heads down uh towards the kind of the if you think the right angle between what's now Turkey and Syria. Yeah, that's it. Yeah, yeah. And he meets with Darius.
因为如果他解不开这个结，他就会看起来像个傻瓜。人们拿着手机站在那儿，伙计们，你知道的——因为如果他解不开这个结，他就会看起来像个傻瓜。人们拿着手机在 Instagram 上看着呢，对吧？这个结——人们拿着手机站在那儿，伙计们，你知道的，所以最后他直接拔出剑把它给砍断了。万岁！他砍断了戈耳狄俄斯之结。因此有了这个成语，对吧？所以这证明了他将征服亚洲，对吧？事情确实如此——所以他——他前往——朝着——如果你认为现在的土耳其和叙利亚之间的直角方向前进的话。是的，就是那样。对，对。他去见了大流士。
He, by this point, has basically thought, hmm, need to sort this out. But he's come with a massive army. Massive army. And he's brought his family. Yeah, he's brought his wife. Yeah, he's brought his mum.
他到这个时候，基本上已经想过了，嗯，需要解决这件事了。但他带着一支庞大的军队来了。庞大的军队。而且他把他的家人也带来了。是的，他带了他的妻子。是的，他带了他的妈妈。
You're right, Sissi Gambus, he's brought his mum. That's madness. But that just shows how little he, you know, what he thinks of Alexander. He just thinks this is some crazy, you know, the Macedonians are primitive. Some barbarian raiding party will smash them up. I'll look really good. And he's trapped Alexander.
你说得对，西绪甘毕斯，他把他的妈妈也带来了。这太疯狂了。但这恰恰说明了他多么不把——你知道的——他怎么看待亚历山大。他只认为这是一个疯狂的——你知道的——马其顿人很原始。某支野蛮人的突袭部队就会把他们粉碎。我会看起来棒极了。而他把亚历山大逼入了绝境。
He's come behind him through the mountains and got him trapped between the mountains. Which is what the Persians always do. Typical Persians. Absolute masters of mountain warfare. I will never get into the mountains with ali ansari you'll just drop off a rock or something yeah throttle you so alexander is trapped there's men are soaked the weather has turned it's all awful and he says to them it's one of those moments that you said tom about him always making the right decision
他从山后迂回到亚历山大身后，把亚历山大困在群山之间。这正是波斯人一贯的做法。典型的波斯人。绝对的山地战大师。我绝不会和阿里·安萨里一起进山，你会被从悬崖上推下去或者别的什么，是的，被勒死。所以亚历山大被困住了。他的手下浑身湿透，天气变了，一切都糟透了。他对他们说——这就是你之前说的汤姆谈到他总是做出正确决定的那些时刻之一——
he says to them well they will just turn around and attack the Persians. You know, this is our God-given chance. And they do. And because they're tightly packed between the sea and the mountains, the Persians can't quite bring their huge numerical superiority to bear. The Macedonians are much better trained. They have their long spears. They have their long spears.
他对他们说，好吧，我们直接转身攻击波斯人。你知道，这是上天赐予我们的机会。他们真的这么做了。而且由于他们紧紧挤在海洋和群山之间，波斯人无法完全发挥他们庞大的人数优势。马其顿人训练有素得多。他们有长矛。他们有长矛。
And Darius runs away. Very foolishly. No, it's not foolish. Well, I think it's foolish. No, it's not foolish. Look at the end result. No, it's not foolish because he's the king. And he has to keep himself alive because he's got to fight on. I suppose.
然后大流士逃跑了。非常愚蠢地。不，这并不愚蠢。嗯，我觉得这很愚蠢。不，这不愚蠢。看看最终结果。不，这并不愚蠢，因为他是国王。他必须保全自己的性命，因为他必须继续战斗。我猜也是。
And you could say it's poor because he dumps his mum mum and his wife and children I think yes but Alexander's very chivalrous well
你可以说这很糟糕，因为他抛弃了他的妈妈、他的妈妈、妻子和孩子，我想是的。但亚历山大非常具有骑士精神。
there's a lovely detail isn't there so Darius has fled Alexander is he gets Darius's tent Darius has a huge bath in the tent
有一个很棒的细节，不是吗？大流士逃跑了，亚历山大占领了大流士的帐篷。大流士的帐篷里有一个巨大的浴缸，
which has been run for him ready for his victory and he's got all this food like a huge spread like a buffet, basically. And one of Alexander's bodyguards, I think a guy called Leonartus,
水已经放好了，准备迎接他的胜利。他有各种各样的食物，就像一个巨大的大拼盘，基本上就像一个自助餐。亚历山大的一个保镖，我想是个叫莱奥纳图斯的家伙，
comes to him and says, Darius has left his mum and his wife and kids and they're making a terrible hullabaloo or weeping and wailing. Can you come and calm them down? And Alexander comes with his great chum, Hephaestion, who's taller than he is. And Darius's mum drops at Hephaestion and who's taller than he is. And Darius's mum drops it.
来到他身边说，大流士把他的妈妈、妻子和孩子留下了，他们正在大吵大闹、哭天喊地。你能去安抚一下他们吗？亚历山大带着他的好死党赫费斯提翁一起来了，赫费斯提翁比他还要高。大流士的母亲倒在赫费斯提翁——比他还要高。大流士的母亲倒在——
Yeah. Yeah. Drops at Hephaestion's feet and says, Oh, you're such a great fellow. Please look after us. And I, and then she's very embarrassed because she realizes what's happened.
对。对。倒在赫费斯提翁的脚下说，哦，你真是个伟大的人物。请照顾好我们。然后——然后她非常尴尬，因为她意识到发生了什么。
And Alexander says something like, he says that I nevermind mother for here too is Alexander. Yes. And people think what's going on there. And all of this definitely really happened. Anyway. So, yeah. so darius's mum according to the story is now team alexander yeah and his wife and he treats them all very nicely doesn't he's very chivalrously and um so he he now he now strikes south so he doesn't head east to to attack um babylonia Persepolis and Susa and all the great cities of the heartlands. And the reason for that is that he has sent away his fleet.
亚历山大说了类似这样的话，他说，没关系，母亲，因为这里也有亚历山大。是的。人们觉得那里发生了什么。所有这一切绝对是真实发生的。不管怎样。所以，是的。所以根据这个故事，大流士的母亲现在是亚历山大阵营的人了。是的，还有他的妻子，他对她们所有人都非常好，不是吗？他非常有骑士风度，而且——所以他——他现在——他现在向南进军——所以他没有向东进军去攻击——巴比伦、波斯波利斯、苏萨以及腹地的所有伟大城市。原因是他已经把他的舰队遣散了。
And so he's basically said, we're going to defeat the Persian fleet by taking away all their harbors. So that's what he's been doing through Asia Minor. And now he goes down the Phoenician coast. And Phoenicia, current day Lebanon day Lebanon is basically it's the great naval power it's the the heartbeat of the Persian navy and so Alexander forces the surrender of all the Phoenician cities except for one Tyre yeah which is the greatest of the lot uh and it's on an island and it's effectively impregnable so Dominic what does Alexander do does he builds a causeway Tom he he's also very cross with the Tyrians isn't he because there's some sort of business about heracles don't they have a statue of heracles or a temple
所以他基本上说过，我们要通过夺走波斯舰队所有的港口来击败他们。这就是他在小亚细亚一直以来所做的事。现在他沿着腓尼基海岸南下。腓尼基，即当今的黎巴嫩——当今的黎巴嫩——基本上它是伟大的海军强国，是波斯海军的心脏，所以亚历山大迫使除了推罗以外的所有腓尼基城市投降——推罗，是的——它是其中最伟大的一座，它坐落在一个岛上，基本上是坚不可摧的。所以，多米尼克，亚历山大做了什么？他修建了一条堤道吗，汤姆？他——他对推罗人也很生气，不是吗？因为有些关于赫拉克勒斯的事情，他们是不是有一个赫拉克勒斯的雕像或神庙，
or something and alexander says he says i'm related to heracles i'd like to come and worship at that temple they say they say no no and he says right that right you don't do that to me so he builds this massive causeway and this is a month's siege it's the one of the amazing things about this story is the time frame so the hollywood version i imagine compresses it and indeed almost all of us i think imaginatively compress it so one event follows another pretty rapidly but i mean as you say it's like a half a year this siege goes on darius is off licking his wounds alexander is laying siege to tyre it's a terrible siege very bloody and then he basically kills them all doesn't he he crucifies him doesn't he yeah he does it's the one moment in his career actually i think the only moment
或者别的什么？亚历山大说，他说，我和赫拉克勒斯有亲缘关系，我想去那座神庙参拜。他们说——他们说，不，不。他说，好啊，好个不字，你不能这样对我。于是他修建了这条巨大的堤道。这是一场长达一个月的围城战。这个故事最神奇的地方之一就是时间框架——所以好莱坞版本我猜压缩了它，事实上，几乎我们所有人在想象中都压缩了它，所以一个事件紧接着另一个事件发生得相当快。但我的意思是，正如你所说，这场围城战持续了大约半年。大流士在舔舐伤口，亚历山大在围攻推罗。这是一场可怕的围城战，非常血腥，然后他基本上把他们全杀了，不是吗？他把他们钉在十字架上了，不是吗？是的，他确实这么做了。这是他职业生涯中唯一的一个时刻——实际上我认为是唯一的时刻——
when you can say he really behaves according to the sources anyway very badly because generally people say badly it's it's it's a calculated atrocity it's it's cromwell at drogata isn't it isn't that what yes kind of it's but it's it's designed to be salutary it's a warning to other cities as to what will happen if they resist yeah and so again i mean you can say of course i mean you, by our standards, it's incredibly brutal, but it serves a purpose. And once again, so it's, I mean, I'm sure he's pissed off at having been kept there for so long. So obviously there's a kind of element of anger there, but there's also an element of calculation and everything Alexander does has calculation. Well, you were saying about him not going east, but going south.
当你可以说他确实表现得——根据史料记载无论如何——非常糟糕时，因为通常人们说糟糕——这是一种精心计算的暴行。这就像克伦威尔在德罗海达一样，不是吗？难道不是吗？是的，有点像。但这——这是为了起到警示作用，是对其他城市如果进行抵抗将会发生什么的一种警告。所以，再次——我的意思是，你可以说，当然——我的意思是，按照我们的标准，这是极其残酷的，但它达到了一个目的。而且再一次，所以它是——我的意思是，我确信他对被困在那里这么久感到很不爽。所以显然其中有一种愤怒的成分，但也有计算的成分，亚历山大做的每一件事都有计算。好吧，你刚才说他没有向东走，而是向南走。
At this point, I think all of this is completely commensurate with relatively limited ambitions. So if you were just doing a raid to get those very rich cities in Asia Minor that had subsequently become something a bit bigger, you would kind of turn south because you would say, why don't I secure the Mediterranean? Phoenicia is very rich. It'd be great for us to knock out a big rival of the Greek kind of trading cities and so on it's kind of the obvious thing to do isn't it but there's the famous anecdote that deriah sends a messenger to alexander saying well look okay you have the the western half i'll have the eastern half yeah and parmenians famously says uh well if i were you alexander i would i would take this
在这一点上，我认为所有这一切完全与相对有限的野心相称。因此，如果你只是去突袭以获得小亚细亚那些后来变得更大一些的非常富裕的城市，你就会转向南方，因为你会说，为什么我不巩固地中海呢？腓尼基非常富裕。对我们来说，消灭希腊贸易城市的一个强大竞争对手等等，将是一件很棒的事情。这似乎是显而易见的事情，不是吗？但有一个著名的轶事，大流士派了一个使者去见亚历山大，说，好吧，好吧，你拥有西半球，我拥有东半球。是的。巴曼尼昂有句名言说，嗯，如果我是你，亚历山大，我会接受这个。
and alexander says so would i if i were parmenian i know that's a great story that's a great story well i think there's a couple of that's a great story but i think there's a couple of letters on that arius sends him one of them is like basically give my wife and mother back and i'll give you loads of money and the other is exactly he says well i'll give you the western bit and alexander says why i've already got it yeah thanks for nothing um well he has uh but the last bit that we should do this and I think that this should be the ending of this episode before we go on to record the second part, is he then invades Egypt. So that's an interesting thing. Do you think that is, if you were just proceeding in terms of sort of short term calculation, would that be an obvious next move?
亚历山大说，如果我是巴曼尼昂，我也会的。我知道，这是个好故事，这是个好故事。嗯，我觉得有几封——这是个好故事，但我认为关于这个有几封信。大流士给他写信，其中一封基本上是说把我的妻子和母亲还给我，我会给你大量的钱。另一封正是他说，嗯，我会给你西部的那部分，而亚历山大说，为什么？我已经得到了。谢谢，什么都没有，嗯。但他有——但我们应该做的最后一部分——我认为这应该成为这一集的结尾，在我们去录制第二部分之前——是他随后入侵了埃及。所以这是一个有趣的问题。你认为——如果你只是从短期计算的角度出发，这会是一个显而易见的下一步行动吗？
I suppose Egypt is very rich, isn't it? And also Egypt, they hate the Persians in Egypt. Yeah, they've been they've been rebelling uh they've periodically throw persian rule off persians come back uh yeah yeah so they're they're very rebellious the persians have been very rude to the egyptian sacred bulls i believe they have been disrespectful not actually true is that not true no it's it's in herodotus. Yeah. So Cambyses, the son of Cyrus, who's the great founder of the Persian Empire, who Alexander greatly admires, is said to have been rude to the Apis bull. I believe it. But this seems to be Egyptian propaganda. I think it's true.
我想埃及非常富裕，对吧？而且在埃及，他们痛恨波斯人。是的，他们一直在叛乱。他们定期摆脱波斯统治，波斯人又卷土重来——是的，是的。所以他们非常叛逆。波斯人对埃及的神圣公牛非常粗鲁，我相信他们一直很不尊重。实际上并非如此。那不是真的吗？不，希罗多德里是这么写的。所以，冈比西斯，居鲁士的儿子，他是波斯帝国的伟大建立者，亚历山大非常崇拜他，据说他对阿匹斯神牛很粗鲁。我相信。但这似乎是埃及的宣传。我认为这是真的。
Because isn't it notable that when Alexander pitches up in Memphis, he makes a great play of being very respectful to this bull? Yeah, but in that, he's behaving as the Persians do. The Persians show respect to everybody's gods. Famously, Cyrus sends the Jews back to the temple. This is your Persephilia coming out. So he arrives in Memphis. The Egyptians, they
因为难道不引人注目的是，当亚历山大来到孟菲斯时，他大肆表现出对这头公牛的极大尊重吗？是的，但在这一点上，他的行为就像波斯人一样。波斯人对所有人的神都表现出尊重。众所周知，居鲁士将犹太人送回神庙。这是你的波斯崇拜在作祟。所以他抵达了孟菲斯。埃及人——他们
hate the Persians. So he's pitched up. They're like, fine, you know, do you want to be pharaoh? They crown him with the double crown of Egypt. But then he does the first thing, I like, fine, you know, do you want to be Pharaoh? They crown him with a double crown of Egypt. But then he does the first thing, I think, in this whole story, which is just very bizarre. Yeah. And is the point at which you sort of think, okay,
痛恨波斯人。所以他出现了。他们心想，好吧，你知道，你想成为法老吗？他们给亚历山大戴上了埃及的双重王冠。但随后他做了整件事中的第一件事——我觉得，好吧，你想成为法老吗？他们为他戴上了埃及的双重王冠。但接着他做了整个故事中我认为非常怪异的第一件事。是的。而且这也是你开始觉得——好吧，
so he's not a normal warlord. He's done something completely, utterly inexplicable, which is he says, you know what I'm going to do now? Having conquered all these cities and darius is out there in the east i'm going to go off for like a massive holiday across the desert of course not i'm going to go on a big trip across the desert to the oracle at siwa which is out in the sort of western desert yeah towards libya if you've played assassin's creed odyssey not assassin's creed odyssey assassin's creed origins you will know the Oasis of Seaworld very well
所以他不是一个普通的军阀。他做了一件完全、彻底令人费解的事，那就是他说，你知道我现在要说什么吗？在征服了所有这些城市、大流士远在东方的情况下，我要去——比如去度个大假，穿过沙漠——当然不是，我要去进行一次大旅行，穿过沙漠去锡瓦的绿洲，它在某种程度上位于西部沙漠——是的，朝着利比亚的方向。如果你玩过《刺客信条：奥德赛》——不是《刺客信条：奥德赛》，是《刺客信条：起源》，你就会对锡瓦绿洲非常熟悉，
because that's where you start in the game. Do you? You do. But on the way, he does something very exciting, doesn't he, Tom? What has he found? He found Alexandria. He does. And you know who tells him to?
因为那是你在游戏中开始的地方。是吗？确实是的。但在路上，他做了一件非常令人兴奋的事，不是吗，汤姆？他发现了什么？他建立了亚历山德里亚。他确实建了。你知道是谁告诉他的吗？
Homer in a dream. Good. Homer says to him, there's an island called Pharos. You should have found a city there alexander wakes up great and off he goes on bucephalus and so i reckon i reckon that that is one of the reasons why alexander is so keen on going to egypt is that it is a part of the fabric of greek yeah apologizing fantasy desire um so there are all these stories about helen and menelaus actually kind of ending up in in egypt that helen stayed in egypt throughout the whole of the trojan war and that they fought
荷马在梦中告诉他的。太棒了。荷马对他说，有一个岛叫法罗斯。你应该在那里建一座城市。亚历山大醒来，太棒了，他骑着布塞法洛斯出发了。所以我猜——我猜这就是为什么亚历山大如此热衷于去埃及的原因之一，因为它是希腊人的虚构、幻想和欲望的结构的一部分——
a kind of fantasy phantasm of helen um herodotus writes about it um aristotle's very interested in egypt so you know there's been quite a lot of interplay hasn't there intellectual and a lot of greek a lot of greek mercenaries have been serving there so that they're very very interested in it and i think that that if you are um you know you you you see yourself as a world conqueror and perhaps as someone who is more than human then egypt is the obvious place to go because um you're going to be crowned as pharaoh. You are then heir to an unfathomably long line of kings. And if you go to Siwa, which is the oracle to Amun,
所以有所有这些关于海伦和墨涅拉俄斯实际上最终来到埃及的故事，海伦在整个特洛伊战争期间都呆在埃及，他们对抗的是海伦的一个虚幻幻影——希罗多德对此有记载——亚里斯多德对埃及非常感兴趣——所以你知道，一直有相当多的互动，不是吗？思想上的互动，而且有很多希腊雇佣兵一直在那里服役，所以他们对此非常非常感兴趣，而且我认为，如果你是——你知道的——你认为自己是一个世界征服者，也许是一个超越人类的存在，那么埃及就是显而易见要去的地方，因为
king of the gods, who the Greeks equate with Zeus, who is Alexander's ultimate ancestor, then you can see why Alexander might think that Ammon Zeus would look on him with favour. And one of the things that's bubbling under is the question of who Alexander's father actually is. I love that. I love that detail. Is it Philip? Or is it?
你将被加冕为法老。然后你就是一段深不可测的漫长国王谱系的继承人。如果你去锡瓦，那是对众神之王阿蒙的神谕所，希腊人将阿蒙等同于宙斯，而宙斯是亚历山大终极的祖先，那么你就能明白为什么亚历山大可能会认为阿蒙-宙斯会青睐他了。潜藏在水面之下的问题之一是关于亚历山大的亲生父亲究竟是谁。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个细节。是腓力吗？还是说——
Or might it in fact be Zeus himself? So there's this story that on her wedding night, I think it is, Olympias was visited by a lightning. She was struck by lightning. And this was Zeus taking possession of her. And Alexander may, in fact, be the son of Zeus. And he goes to, so he goes across the desert. And this is no, so going to Alexandria kind of makes sense, going to the site of Alexandria.
或者实际上可能是宙斯本人？所以有一个故事说，在她的新婚之夜，我想是的，奥林匹亚丝受到了一道闪电的造访。她被闪电击中了。这就是宙斯占有了她。亚历山大实际上可能是宙斯的儿子。他去——所以他穿过了沙漠。这并不是——所以去亚历山大里亚在某种程度上说得通，去亚历山大里亚的遗址。
Because if you're thinking about creating a new empire in the eastern Mediterranean, you need a port. You need a port. And that makes complete sense. This is the port that will connect Greece and Macedonia with your new Egyptian conquest. But then going across the desert, which he does for days, the sources say he does this for days. They tell all these stories.
因为如果你正在考虑在东地中海建立一个新帝国，你需要一个港口。你需要一个港口。这完全说得通。这就是将希腊和马其顿与你新征服的埃及连接起来的港口。但随后穿过沙漠，史料记载他这样做了好几天，他确实走了好几天。他们讲述了所有这些故事。
There's a brilliant bit in Arian's account where Arian says, well, there are multiple versions about how they basically fight. They clearly get lost in the desert. So he's gone with quite a small group of the key mates, his old mates from boarding school. And Arian says, there are various different accounts about how they actually found the oasis, but the one I go with is the one by Ptolemy,
阿里安的记载中有一个精彩的片段，阿里安说，好吧，关于他们基本上是如何作战的，有多个版本的说法。他们显然在沙漠里迷路了。所以他带着一小群核心死党一起去了，也就是他寄宿学校的老朋友们。阿里安说，关于他们实际上是如何找到绿洲的，有各种不同的说法，但我采用的是托勒密的说法，
who is one of his great chums, who becomes pharaoh of Egypt himself. He says, because Ptolemy is a king and can therefore be trusted. And he says, Ptolemy says that they were shown to the oasis by some talking snakes. So that must be true. Because a king wouldn't lie.
他是亚历山大的好死党之一，后来自己成为了埃及的法老。他说——因为托勒密是个国王，因此是值得信赖的。他说，托勒密说，他们是由几条会说话的蛇带到绿洲去的。所以这一定是真的。因为国王是不会撒谎的。
So I don't think there's any reason, Tom, for us to doubt that they were not. They're shown to the oasis by the talking snakes. They pitch up. Now, the Oracle of Amon. I mean, Amon is a really interesting god because he's not quite – he's got horns, hasn't he? He's got the horns of a ram. Yeah.
所以我认为没有任何理由，汤姆，让我们怀疑他们不是——他们是由会说话的蛇带到绿洲的。他们出现了。现在，阿蒙的神谕。我的意思是，阿蒙是一个非常有趣的神，因为他并不完全是——他长着角，不是吗？他长着公羊的角。是的。
And these are important because they will, again, remember these horns of a ram guys. Yeah. They'll come back. We'll come back to them. So Alexander goes on his own into the temple. The others all lurk on the steps or something, you know, having a drink and comparing sunburn. I think
这些角很重要，因为它们会——再次提醒大家，记住公羊的角，伙计们。是的。它们会回来的。我们会回来的。所以亚历山大独自一人进入了神庙。其他人都在台阶上徘徊什么的，你知道，喝着饮料，对比着晒伤的程度。我想
at this point some of them might reasonably be saying this trip has not quite turned out as I expected. A stag do's don't go. Talking snakes. Your Bullingdon impersonation is worth doing the subject for that alone. Yeah, it is. But the
在这个时候，他们中的一些人可能会合理地认为，这次旅行的结果并不完全像我预期的那样。单身汉派对可别这么搞。会说话的蛇。你模仿布林顿公学学生的腔调，单凭这一点这个话题就值得一做。是的，确实如此。但
oracle Amon is a very peculiar oracle. I mean, I still think it's hard to conceive that taking place in front of you, the straight face, because it's basically a stone, isn't it? A moving stone. What I know about the oracle at Seaways, it's one of the very
阿蒙神谕是一个非常奇特的神谕。我的意思是，我仍然觉得很难想象这会在你面前发生，还要保持严肃的面孔，因为它基本上是一块石头，不是吗？一块会移动的石头。我对锡瓦神谕的了解是，它是基督教时期
last places to remain pagan in the Christian period. It's a stone that they put on a big sort of tray, and they carry it about and it has like dangling bells from it. And you ask your question, and they shuffle about with the stone
最后几个保持异教信仰的地方之一。这是一块他们放在某种大托盘上的石头，他们抬着它到处走，上面挂着铃铛。你提出问题，他们就在托盘上移动石头，石头通常会指向写有你问题答案的纸条。但难道他没有一个完全私密的——？是的，确实有。据说是这样的。而且有不同的说法。
on the tray, where the stone directs often to pieces of paper with the answers written down to your question. But doesn't he have a completely private? Yes, there is. It is supposedly. And there are different accounts.
关于——内容有不同的说法。当然有。他从未透露过说了什么。但有些人说，正如亚历山大大帝故事的顶级儿童版中所写的那样，在孟菲斯的酒馆里，士兵们交流着八卦和谣言，
There are different accounts of what. Of course there are. He never reveals what was said. But some people say, as a top children's version of the Alexander the Great story has it in the taverns of Memphis the soldiers exchange gossip and rumours
有些人说，那是他对他们说，我是否充分为我父亲腓力之死复仇了？我是否向波斯人报仇了？他们说，不，不，因为你的父亲不是腓力，你的父亲是宙斯。而此时，关键在于，汤姆，你认为他相信这一点吗？基于他随后的行为，你认为他觉得自己是一个神的儿子吗？我可不这么认为。他会给出一个非常 evasive（敷衍）的回答。好吧。所以这里有一个有趣的回答，那就是，你见过据说在阿富汗一口井里发现的那枚金币吗？没有。
and some people say that it's that he says to them have I sufficiently avenged the death of my father Philip and have I got revenge over the persians and they say no no because your father is not philip your father is zeus and at that point now the
有些人说，他对他们说：“我是否充分为我父亲腓力之死复仇了？我是否对波斯人复仇了？”他们说：“不，不，因为你的父亲不是腓力，你的父亲是宙斯。”而在那个时候，
thing is tom do you think he believes this do you think he thinks he's the son of a god based on his subsequent conduct? I just don't think that. It's going to give a very evasive answer. Well, okay. So there's an interesting answer to this, which is, have you seen this gold coin that was supposedly found down a well in Afghanistan? No.
汤姆，你觉得他真的相信这一点吗？根据他后来的行为，你觉得他认为自己是神的儿子吗？我只是不这么认为。这将是一个非常搪塞的回答。好吧，好吧。所以这里有一个有趣的答案，那就是，你见过据说在阿富汗一口井里发现的那枚金币吗？没有。
Is that one of them, Iqanum, or one of those? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
那是其中之一吗，艾卡努姆（Iqanum），还是其中的某个地方？不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
It's, um, it's, it's Southern Afghanistan and there's a well, and they found a whole, supposedly a whole stash of a massive, massive hoard of, of,
那是——那是阿富汗南部，有一口井，他们在那里发现了一整批——据说是整整一大批、一大批的——
uh, of coins. And, um, they kind of started turning up in, this is the 1990s. I think I'm the Taliban. Uh,
硬币。而且——它们开始出现，这是 20 世纪 90 年代。塔利班统治时期，我想。
and these coins started turning up, filtering out. Um, and one of them is a 1990s, I think on the Taliban. And these coins started turning up, filtering out. And one of them is a gold coin, which has an elephant on one side and a picture of what's clearly Alexander on the other. And he has a kind of elephant hood, a hood made of a scalped elephant. And he has the horns of amun and it seems likely because there are also a whole series of of of coins which were definitely minted um in alexander's lifetime showing elephants uh for reasons that will come to
这些硬币开始出现并流出。其中有一枚金币，一面刻着一头大象，另一面刻着显然是亚历山大的头像。他戴着某种大象兜帽，一个由剥皮的大象制成的兜帽。他头上长着阿蒙的角，这似乎很可能，因为还有一系列在亚历山大有生之年绝对铸造的硬币，上面显示着大象——出于以后当亚历山大入侵印度时会谈到的原因——
in due course when alexander invades india um and so it the thesis is that this is a coin that dates it's the only it's the only thing that dates from his lifetime because there are subsequent coins with him with ram's horns which are minted by Ptolemy as in yeah you know Mr Snake um and Ptolemy has his own interest in in branding Alexander as a god yeah of course because the egyptians think of pharaohs as well because alexander yes but alexander's body ends up in in of course in egypt so so ptolemy has a kind of massive interest in saying i have the body of a god yeah so that and as you can tell from the talking snake stuff quite a lot of these stories are not entirely reliable yeah don't tell me you're going to diss ptolemy's reliability so I think so I think it to that extent it's difficult to know but if this coin is genuine then that would suggest
所以这个论点是，这是一枚可以追溯到——这是唯一一件可以追溯到他有生之年的东西，因为随后有戴着羊角的他的硬币，是由托勒密铸造的——也就是，是的，你知道的，蛇先生——而托勒密自己对将亚历山大包装成神有着自己的利益，是的，当然，因为埃及人认为法老也是神，因为亚历山大——是的，但是亚历山大的遗体最终留在了埃及，所以托勒密有着巨大的利益去宣称“我拥有神的遗体”，是的。因此，正如你从会说话的蛇的故事中所能看出的那样，这些故事中有相当一部分并不是完全可靠的。是的，别告诉我你要贬低托勒密的可靠性。所以我想——所以我认为从这个程度上讲，很难知道，但如果这枚硬币是真的，那就表明——
and it's minted in Alexander's lifetime then that would suggest that it is coming from Alexander himself that still doesn't mean that um Alexander does necessarily believe it I mean it might be for propagandistic purposes yeah I don't know but I but I think the board you know in Greece the border between the divine and the human is is much moreous, much more amorphous than it is for us. I think that's definitely true, Tom. And I think as well, some historians say that Greece has been ever more tightly connected to Egyptian and Persian ideas of kingship in recent years. And the idea of a kind of sacral, I'm using a Tom Holland word. Yeah, you are.
而且它是在亚历山大有生之年铸造的，那就表明这是来自亚历山大本人的意愿。这仍然不意味着亚历山大一定会相信这一点——我的意思是，这可能是为了政治宣传的目的。是的，我不知道，但我认为——你知道，在希腊，神圣与人类之间的界限比我们想象的要模糊得多，更加多孔。我认为这绝对是真的，汤姆。而且我也认为，一些历史学家说，近年来希腊与埃及和波斯的君主制思想联系得越来越紧密。一种神圣的——我正在使用汤姆·霍兰德的词汇。是的，你确实在用。
Of a kind of sacral kingship. Welcome to my world. So when Philip was assassinated going into the stadium, which we mentioned in the first half, he was about to join a procession of images of the gods. There was going to be images of the Olympians and another image of Philip himself kind of as a god. So already that kind of idea that a king is very like a god, even godly um or godlike rather i should say is sort of in the ether and so it kind of explains why alexander might believe it in a sort of weird way and it's something that that really kicks in in in the decades after alexander's as death where so the athenians that they greet this um kind of you know uh warlord macedonian warlord um as a god because and they say well because you're on the earth and the god the other
一种神圣的君主制。欢迎来到我的世界。所以当腓力在进入体育场时被刺杀——我们在前半部分提到过——他正要加入一个神明雕像的游行队伍。那里将会有奥林匹斯诸神的雕像，以及腓力本人作为神明的另一座雕像。因此，国王非常像神、甚至具有神性——或者说神圣，我应该这么说——这种想法已经在空气中弥漫了，这在某种程度上解释了为什么亚历山大可能会以某种诡异的方式相信它，而且这是在亚历山大死后的几十年里真正开始盛行的东西，所以雅典人们把这个——你知道的——马其顿军阀——当成神来迎接，因为——他们说，因为你在大地上，而其他
gods aren't and we need right it's not a very good reason i don't think that's quite a good reason it's quite good they they greet him by carrying giant phalluses through the streets of athens right that would i would find that a bit disconcerting personally but um um so yes so those borders are porous we but i think and i don't know whether this coin is i think it's generally not thought to be uh authentic but there are various serious you think it is okay and and i am not remotely qualified to see i think, I think Alexander's subsequent behaviour makes more sense if you think he thinks he's really touched by something because this is the point I think.
神不在，我们需要——这并不是一个很好的理由，我不认为这是一个很好的理由。这挺不错的，他们通过在雅典街头抬着巨大的阳具来迎接他，好吧，就我个人而言，我会觉得这有点令人不安，但是——所以，是的，这些界限是多孔的，我们——但我认为，我不知道这枚硬币是否——我认为人们通常不认为它是真实的，但有各种各样的观点——你认为它是真的，好吧——而我根本没有资格去看，我只想说，如果你认为亚历山大真的被某种神圣力量触及过，那么他随后的行为就更有意义了，因为我认为这就是关键所在。
Well, he's Achilles. He's Achilles. So Achilles is a hero. And, you know, we've talked about this before. Hero, the idea of a hero is, you know, you are a son of a god or you have something of the divine about you. That is a status that is kind of universally recognized in the Greek world. I'm sure Alexander thinks that he occupies that position, that he's a hero in that sense. But whether he thinks he's a god, it's impossible to say.
好吧，他是阿基里斯。他是阿基里斯。所以阿基里斯是个英雄。而且，你知道，我们之前讨论过这个。英雄，英雄的概念就是，你知道，你是神的儿子，或者你身上有某种神性。在希腊世界，这是一种普遍认可的地位。我确信亚历山大认为自己占据了那个位置，他在那个意义上是一个英雄。但至于他是否认为自己是神，这是不可能说的。
We're at the end of this episode so alexander is there in egypt with his mates tom holland's done a fantastic impersonation of the mate do you want to give us that one more time yeah top level yeah there we go and um there they are with prince harry and the others uh gearing up they're all there in egypt now i think this is the point at which anybody else might have packed up and gone home. But of course, Alexander doesn't. He goes on. And what happens next? We will discover next time, won't we, Tom? If you have Pothos, you have Pothos.
我们正处于这一集的尾声，所以亚历山大和他的死党们现在身在埃及，汤姆·霍兰德对死党进行了精彩的模仿。你想再给我们来一次吗？顶级水平，太棒了，就是这样。然后——他们和哈里王子以及其他人都在那里，正在做准备。他们现在全都在埃及了。我想这就是其他人可能会收拾行李回家的时刻。但当然，亚历山大没有。他继续前行。接下来会发生什么？我们下次会发现的，不是吗，汤姆？如果你有“渴望”（Pothos），你就是有“渴望”。
We'll see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们明天见。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。